my name is Brenna rose I'm 35 years old
and I live in around down by the river
except it's actually a really cool band
that I've added a ton of Technology to
today we're gonna be talking about all
the customizations I've done to this
baby so it can be ready for my high tech
lifestyle so you know that we've been
calling this video series out of office
well I was tired of sitting at the same
desk every day so I gave up my apartment
and most of my stuff and I bought a big
converted van which I'm now living in
full time as I Drive around the country
I've been at it for more than a month
now when I first bought Ashley the Beast
she was grossly underpowered she had
outlets all over the inside which was
great but I couldn't run anything off of
them unless she was plugged in to shore
power or unless the generator was
running which is loud and not good for
him kognito camping so I brought her to
am solar in Springfield Oregon and they
really hooked me up what am I talking
about I'm talking about 320 watts of
solar panels that feed down at about 17
amps straight into my brand new 200 amp
hour lithium battery this thing is
beautiful not only is it the same size
as my old 80 amp our lead acid battery
but I can drain all the way down to
about 15 percent where's the lead acid
you risk damaging it after you go past
50 this gives me way more usable power I
have all of that running into a beast of
a 3000 watt hybrid inverter not only can
it power all the little things in the
van it can handle the big-ticket items
too including the air conditioner
although only for about an hour so
before I deplete the battery about 50%
but still that's sick with all that
stuff together I can keep my fridge
constantly cold and all my gadgets
charged without ever really needing to
worry about running out of power that in
itself has allowed me to basically go
completely off the grid it's huge let me
tell you about some of the other stuff
so obviously I sleep in here I've got a
lot of gadgets in here so security is
gonna be really important to me
so I got the top-of-the-line system from
VIPRE this included the 50 806 and the
GPS Smart Start system it's a 2-way
system so if my alarm goes off I'll know
about it through my keychain or through
my smartphone app even if I'm far away
the system also has a microphone which
can detect the crash of glass but it's
made for some humorous situations for
example
even with that Viper system I wanted to
make sure my gadgets were especially
safe so I completely dismantled this
cabinet and I installed the Viking safe
vs 38 BL with biometric fingerprint
scanner it's big enough to fit my laptop
microphones recorders hard drives all
that stuff and I've installed it in such
a way that taking it out would take a
long time hopefully while the alarms
blaring the fingerprint scanner is kind
of just showing off but whatever it's a
teched-out van so I'm running with it
I'm also using this little Bluetooth GPS
dongle called automatic it basically
installs right into your vehicle's
Diagnostics port and you can tell you
things about the vehicle's health I can
even call the authorities if you get
into an accident it's just an extra
layer of security but what about tunes
well as you can see the stereo system is
pretty out of date oh just kidding this
is actually the top-of-the-line pioneer
AV IC 8100 NEX
it's got a capacitive touch screen it
runs Android auto and apple carplay has
its own built-in navigation and even
supports backup cameras which has made
my life much much easier
the guys who installed it had to slice
open the dash and expand it from the
single VIN slot to a double din slot but
it managed to make it match perfectly
they also built this amazing little end
cap thing to make it just a little bit
more subtle it's maybe my favorite
modification so now I had this sweet
stereo head but it was all coming
through these two wimpy in-dash speakers
so the guys installed two phoenix gold
6x9 is right behind the front two chairs
and a kicker base station right
underneath the table I now have a very
very satisfying amount of base
and then my friend made a custom EQ to
match the band's resonant frequency if
by no means an audiophile grade system
but it sounds really really nice what
else when I first got the van it was
filled with small incandescent bulbs
which were a real power suck so I went
through and replaced them all with high
output high efficiency LEDs gives me the
same amount of light for about one-fifth
the amount of power consumption which
makes a huge difference overnight but
when I want to set the mood I've got
these this is the N mu cube it's a small
battery-powered cube it's got three
white settings and then it Scrolls
through every color you can possibly
imagine when you get to one you like you
hit the button again and you freeze it I
use four of these things across the van
and it really helps create a more
relaxing atmosphere it's kind of like
being in first class on a Virgin
Atlantic flight or so I imagine but
honestly some of my favorite alterations
have been the little mods like the
moment when I first realized there was
an inch and a half gap behind these two
seats in a solid piece of wood up here I
finally had a place to hang my suits or
finding a place for these two code hooks
where I probably wouldn't lose an eye
ball I also found an out-of-the-way
place to mount my garbage can with
bungee cords we've been using this
plastic sink liner so my gray water tank
doesn't fill up quite as quickly these
may seem like small things but when
you're living in a small space these
little conveniences add up really
quickly so that's most of the
customizations I've made to the beast
here but there are more on the way and
if you've got ideas for some I want to
hear about it let me know through
Twitter or Instagram and don't forget to
follow at connected States com I hope to
see you out there on the road and thank
you for watching